hi there uh here's what we're gonna do
today um i was gonna
show you a bit of my life i do more in
life than just
uh study korean or study languages
um hockey three times a week is
something i very much enjoy and i
typically drop by the office in the
afternoon i mean
uh i'm um
basically
semi-retired
but i have an office where we have our
wood business and where we have link and
i like to drop by there in the afternoon
or come back here and do some work or
study or keep up to date with my various
and sundry you know
the forum at link and facebook and
answering my youtube
people who question
post comments and stuff like that
so very quickly i'm going to show you my
morning
uh and then i'm going to come back again
and i'm doing that just so you don't
always just look at me here so you see a
little bit of my day then i can come
back and i'm going to answer a question
uh that i received from one of my uh
viewers on a link member
and that is like how can you get to a
stage where you can have a meaningful
conversation in six months because she's
from novi sad in
serbia and there's going to be a
polyglot conference there in october and
she wants to become a true polyglot so
more about that later but first i'll
show you a bit of my day
so today is hockey day so
i went to pick up one of our
members whose car is in the garage and
couldn't make it
and he's just gonna come out the door
here
corny ross
you're gonna
be on my uh youtube channel
all right so i'm going to make you guys
famous
you're going to be on my youtube channel
here we are where the gold team are
playing the blues today
you guys i'm scared no we don't want
skin depends whose depends whose
now gordy is our goaltender
known as six-pack
turned into a overnight trunk
and uh you're our captain right john a
couple of those hitchhikers
partners
i i wish i wish there were more of them
they're waiting outside right so why
don't you guys learn languages this this
is all for language you know i'm
studying korean right now right yeah for
you
should i just stop this and get dressed
so we can play hockey
that's what i'm working towards that's
what i'm working towards
it hasn't helped you with y'all steve so
we define the language
okay
and this is where the rink is it's in
north vancouver
it's called the canlan
ice sports
there's uh some of our members driving
away
and normally i walk into the arena like
this except i've already put my stuff
away in the car
and i'll give you a bit of a shot from
the inside as well
so as you walk in here
the doors open automatically and there
are a total of three rings and now
they've shut down we just finished
playing our game
here and that's 12 35 i'm gonna go out
for lunch
and there's some little kids here
yeah but there seems to be no activity
quite often there is
and uh what else have we got here
you know we've even got
uh there are two defibrillators and i'm
one of the people trained to use them i
hope i never have to use one and there
you have it this is where i play three
times a week just to continue with a day
in the life of a korean language learner
i finished my hockey
and now i am coming here
to
where i went on the very first day
uh which is sushi town
and it's right by mcdonald's i think you
can see it there and i'm going to walk
in the door and if i'm lucky i'll find
that same
waitress and uh hopefully
she'll think that i have improved
claire
um
so this is an answer to nina nina yolich
i think it's pronounced in novi sad
we have had conversations in french and
in english
if i ever learn serbian which i hope i
will do then i will speak to her in
serbian at link
and she uh said there's a polyglot
conference in novi sad in october and
she wants to become a true polyglot how
does one get to uh to the to a level
where one can have a meaningful
conversation in a language in just six
months all right
first of all there are these polyglot
conferences there was one in hungary i
couldn't go there because i was in
vienna a few weeks earlier and i wasn't
just gonna hang around
there's apparently one in berlin there's
talk about one in montreal
and now there's talk about this one in
novi sad
as i understand it largely this is for
people who speak four five six seven
languages they get together
and you know it's like
i don't know a curling bond spiel or a
hockey tournament people do what they
like to do
they meet up they talk in the different
languages that they share and it's a
great social event
and
contacts are made and it stimulates
people
like for example nina here to improve
their languages so it's extremely
positive it doesn't really seem to be
aimed at the person who has one language
and has been forever trying to learn
another language and i think that is the
vast majority of people who are language
learners or could be language learners
or would like to be language learners
and i wish there was some way we could
get those people to realize
that the most important thing about
these polyglot conferences is that there
are so many people who speak five six or
seven languages and that doing that is
not such an extraordinary thing it's
just a matter of interest applying
yourself and sticking with it so that's
just by way of background now
uh and also before i answer nina's
question uh very quick comment about
when i went to the korean or at least
the sushi restaurant run by koreans and
i had a brief exchange with my
friend the waitress claire she was very
busy i couldn't really i don't like to
just sit there and film people when
they're busy serving tables and stuff
like that
but
on two occasions she came over just to
humor me and she kind of threw some
korean at me the first time she said
something like you know do you need
anything more and something about uh
pediomnica or something
i wasn't expecting it
i said
uh you know repeat that
then i said no no
i don't need anything and then uh later
she invited said uh
it's again words that i know
but it said is it cold outside
and i wasn't expecting it so one thing
about being able to respond to
conversations and stuff like that
is that that it's not just the language
we also have to have
context we have to almost be able to
anticipate
what people are going to say
it takes a lot of practice so
in order to be comfortable in
conversations you have to have a lot of
exposure
a lot of exposure not only in the sort
of
form of input reading and listening and
building up your vocabulary but our
actual practical experience of speaking
to people in a variety of situations so
that the next time someone says to me uh
is a cold outside i'll be expecting that
kind of question i'll be expecting those
words i'll be able to respond
so
all of that by way of saying as you know
i believe that in order in order to have
a meaningful conversation you need lots
of vocabulary because you can't expect
the other person to dumb down their
conversation to whatever limited range
of vocabulary you have you have to have
a very large passive vocabulary and then
you have your more limited active
vocabulary that you can kind of
use to kind of work around uh you know
twist to what you're trying to say and
make the odd mistake and it doesn't
matter but if you don't understand what
they're saying
then you can't even get started in a
meaningful conversation and to
understand what they're saying you ain't
need a large vocabulary and b you need
experience so my strategy would be if
it's six months from now i would spend
the better part of three
months
fundamentally on input and i would get
as much of the language in me as
possible if you have the patience to do
what luca does where you translate from
the target language into your own
language and then translate back into
the target language i've never done that
and i'm not disciplined enough to do it
i'm not writing an exam
you know but i can imagine that it works
well and certainly luca would
is a perfect example of someone who
learns languages very well and very
quickly so you might want to try that
because it works for luca if you enjoy
doing it
so very heavy to input for the first
three months at least
a system like link but listening and
reading to the same content some way of
reviewing vocabulary
i like to tag phrases and words so that
i notice them again when i listen and
read
then after about three months you're
gonna have to start speaking and speak
to a variety of people
uh if you can't
uh you know go to the country like if
you're learning hungarian you just go
next door from novi sad so that's
practical or romania
on the other hand
if you're learning japanese you can't
just go there for whatever period of
time so you have to try and build up
your contacts via skype it's not as good
there's no way it's as good
but
the last three months i would gradually
step up my speaking i would speak maybe
three times a week for the month four
and then i would speak every day for
month five and even step it up more than
that for month six so during that six
month period the first three months is
to become familiar with the language
build up a base vocabulary have some
opportunity of understanding what people
are saying
because you don't want to spend the
first three months like if you spend an
hour talking to someone and all you can
ask them about is the weather and how
old you are to me that's a waste of time
you're better off to spend that hour
listening and reading or reviewing
vocabulary but when you get to a certain
level now that you can have a more
challenging conversation where you
actually try to express some thoughts
okay then you can start stepping up your
uh speaking
and put yourself into different
situations have a variety of people that
you speak to make sure that they're
sound if you're going on skype that the
sound quality is good that they're
interesting people that you're not just
putting in the time straining to
understand because the crackling of the
internet is makes us sound
unintelligible or because the person is
not very interesting to talk to so get
good partners or if you're lucky enough
go to the country for two three weeks
and if you were to do that like i would
love to go to korea for two three weeks
at the end of my uh three months
challenge here whether i'll be able to
justify flying all the way to korea just
to do that remains to be seen
so there you have it
that's what i would do in order to get
to where i can have meaningful
conversations within a six month time
frame thanks for listening